[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et échanger à travers
les sujets de société
alors ce soir ils sont futurs bacheliers
étudiants ou viennent tout juste
d'entrer sur le marché du travail mais
ils ont tous un point commun ils ont une
vingtaine d'années depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
on parle d'une jeunesse sacrifiée mais
qu'est ce qu'être jeune en sapeur de
kobe 19
c'est la question que nous allons
développer que nos invités fiona le
jambon soir qu'il en soit vous êtes
actuellement en service civique et vous
vivez à elancourt lucas andrieu bonsoir
vous êtes étudiant en deuxième année de
licence à l'université versailles saint
quentin et élus de 1 tera sauce et vous
habitez à vélizy villacoublay
sylvain mention bonsoir bornes vous êtes
lycéen en bac professionnel et vous
habitez à trappes et sandrine bustos
bonsoir bonsoir il est psychologue vous
exercez au centre terap 6a voisins le
bretonneux
alors les témoignages et les articles se
multiplient sur les difficultés que
peuvent rencontrer certains jeunes en
cette période de crise à saint germain
en laye la ville a décidé de mettre en
place un dispositif d'écouté quelques
explications de sylvie abers du puits
elle est première adjointe à la jeunesse
à la ville
la ville de saint germain en tenait à
être aux côtés de ces jeunes qui nous
l'entendons tous depuis plusieurs
semaines expriment des difficultés
rencontrées de toutes sortes et il nous
semblait important à la ligne de saint
germain de pouvoir aussi offrir la
possibilité à nos jeunes de pouvoir
rencontrer en présentiel quelqu'un du
corps médical
on pense beaucoup à peut-être nous à
notre population estudiantine qui peut
se sentir un peu perdus dans un espace
beaucoup plus plus grands et qui aurait
besoin vraiment de de pouvoir échanger
et se recadrer le docteur sully en ce
qu'on s'est proposé pour assurer une
permanence qui se tiendra tous les
jeudis de 17h à 20h à l'espace vers à
l'espace berra est à cinq minutes à pied
du vieux airs et les jeunes ont pris
rendez-vous par une adresse qui vient
d'être créée qui écoute jeunes jeunes au
pluriel à saint germain en laye pour la
paix de fer et cette adresse mail sera
donc monitorer par notre service
jeunesse et sports et pourra donc donner
des créneaux généralement en une demi
heure pour une consultation avec le
docteur hans contre sandrine busto je
vais commencer avec vous revoilà une
collectivité qui se mobilisent sur la
question des difficultés rencontrées
parisien est-ce que c'est aussi
nécessaire que les collectivités soient
présentes dans ces moments là oui il me
semble que c'est quand même une écoute
particulière que l'on doit apporter un
autre jeunesse dans cette période très
particulière
une jeunesse ou
c'est une période qui a qui connaît
quand même des gens des enjeux très
spécifiques
c'est difficile pour tout le monde les
plus petits les adultes les jeunes
connaissent
voilà des exigences de réussite scolaire
il ya des choix d'orientation
professionnelle des choix d'orientation
formation dans une période où la
distanciation sociale
la capacité de ce projet de se projeter
à court moyen ou long terme rend cette
de pression encore plus difficile donc
il me semble en échec c'est quelque
chose qui doit être portée à la fois par
nos élus mais au fond par par tous les
citoyens que ce soit au sein la cellule
familiale au sein des collectivités au
sein des associations
et là je me retourne permet mais les
collègues ce soir les associations
étudiantes qui doivent aussi jouer un
rôle fondamental dans cette dans cet
accompagnement est dans cette écoute
alors justement les jeunes on en a trois
avec nous ce soir qui ont 17 20 et 24
ans fiona gélin je commençais avec vous
justement est ce que c'est une période
plus difficile qu'avant l'accroché 19
m'a forcément c'est une période
difficile c'est un peu ils sortent d'une
période de vous extraire en fait c'est
un peu ce que je retiens de tout ça
c'est moi encore j'ai de la chance parce
que j'ai je suis diplômé début juin 2020
mais j'ai expérimenté on va dire le film
en tant qu'étudiante mais je vois encore
mes petites marques pour étudiantes
moment c'était vraiment très compliqué
parce que déjà quand on est étudiant et
qu'il n'y a pas de copie de 19 mais
juste qu'on les étudiants on se cherche
on envie d'expérimenter on a envie de
faim même juste de socialiser de c'est
en faisant des expériences en testage
mais c'est en fait ce qu'on peut être
qu'on y fait et là bas on était un peu
bloquée jusqu'au pas pu s'approcher des
sylvain mentions vous êtes le plus jeune
ce soir vous devrez vous devriez passer
votre bac cette année
est-ce que c'est plus compliqué pour
vous moi je dirais peut-être pas sa
salle ses preuves ne change pas après
c'est vrai que avec le co vide on ne
sait pas si ces preuves sont toujours
maintenues ce qui reste une difficulté
supplémentaire
lucas andrieu est ce que vous partagez
le sentiment de vos collègues ou de
madame boussioux bien sûr que c'est très
compliqué on est jeune et d'avoir 20 en
2020 elle dépend du financier déjà on a
qu'elle marchera en france 38 % de la
population étudiante qui est boursière
et 20% des étudiants qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté d'après l'insee il ya
eu énormément de jobs perdus de perte
d'activité rémunérée
d'un point de vue social c'est
extrêmement dur parce qu'on a plus
aucune interaction et quand on accourt
de 8h à 19h tous les jours un forfait en
plus on peut plus rien faire et donc oui
c'est triste et très compliqué et niveau
scolaire une pression en plus qui
s'ajoute avec confinement d un nouveau
mode de fonctionnement qui doit
assimiler notamment pour les premières
années qui sont pour nous confier son
décrochage
donc oui c'est extrêmement dur et
chantage aux centaines boussioux c'est
ce que vous avez vu plus de patients
venir consulter c'est ce cas quelles
sont les demandes les besoins qui
peuvent ressortir de vos consultations
oui en effet il ya un accroissement à la
fin des consultations pour l'apparition
de tout bleu
anxieux dépressifs troubles du sommeil
des conduites alimentaires truc phobique
voirie des noirs idées suicidaires et
passage à l'acte donc moi il me semble
important quand même de deux raclées
peut-être avec un éclairage particulier
celui d'une psychologue où on entend
parler de distanciation social de
distanciation dans la sphère familiale
et moi je pense qu'il est fondamental ne
pas se distancier de soi même
quelles que soient les modalités ne pas
jamais renoncer en fait à ce que l'on
est et quel que soit dévoilé les chemins
que l'on peut emprunter ce soit au
travers d'activités créatrices que ce
soit parce qu'en fait il faut quand même
réfléchir la différence entre isolement
et solitude la solitude peut-être un
moment opportun pour en effet
s'interroger et prendre soin de soi
isolement et quand même délétère et à
les esprits oui je vous écoute
non les esprits et de pouvoir en effet
être en mesure de pouvoir que un
isolement prolongé subi qui semble ne
pas avoir de fin peut avoir des actions
et des conséquences sur la santé
psychique et la souffrance et auquel cas
on est jeté il faut rompre cet isolement
ont parlé michèle flournoy gars parler
en effet des conditions économiques très
difficiles pour les étudiants voilà en
libéral aussi on adapte nos tarifs on
pourra peut être parler du check up ci
qui va être mis en place
le gouvernement a fait cette annonce
mais quelles que soient les voilà c'est
quelque chose à prendre vraiment au
sérieux
fiona legein vous êtes actuellement en
service civique est ce que c'est une
deuxième avait fini vos études au début
de la cause de la crise de la cofidis
parce que vous avez changé en cours de
route vous aviez déjà ce projet de
service dans un coin de votre tête
j'avais déjà un projet mais je pense que
le cep cependant tous les événements qui
sont arrivés ça ça accentue mon envie
parce que déjà j'avais peut-être prendre
le temps avant de rentrer sur le marché
du travail est de faire le métier pour
lequel j'ai été formé mais là avec
l'idée de en fait de deux devra remplir
et de faire quelque chose je me sens
utile et en même temps sans trop de
m'engager dans quelque chose sachant que
c'est une période floue donc vous
engager tout de suite dans le mythique
des personnes tu veux savait forcément
que ça les a déformé par les
circonstances
du coup j'avais pas envie de commencer
dans un moment où ça allait forcément je
pense des formes aimons mais a priori
sur sûr absent gros j'ai été formé pour
la petite patrie ciel et et commencer la
ensemble psychomotricienne dans un monde
de socothyd je vous disais j'avais peur
ça me dégoûte en fait du métier ça me
fait un petit peu peur et du coup
j'avais envie de m'engager ailleurs est
de continuer à apprendre sur le terrain
autrement par l'intermédiaire du service
c'est une invention justement on rentre
aussi peut-être dans cette notion vous
êtes actuellement en stage dans une
entreprise saint-quentinoise
est-ce que c'était votre premier choix
est ce que ça vous a fait réfléchir au
national parle d'un certain flou est-ce
que trouver ce stage a été difficile
ouais ce sage c'est vraiment difficile à
trouver
j'ai dû demander de l'aide à des
personnes a déjà enfin de le trouver
donc c'est vraiment pas une tâche
évidente maintenant de trouver un stage
ou un emploi pour un étudiant ou lycéen
lucas andrieu vous vous êtes en 2e année
vous avez en tout sa particularité vous
faites une double licence mais vous
n'avez pas revu les bancs de la fac
depuis le 2ème confinement qu'est-ce qui
est le plus dur se motiver être
concentré ben peut être un peu tout tout
mélanger la motivation à apprendre et à
ce gibier cours à distance
elle est faible elle se ressent au près
tous les étudiants avec intérêt ce on a
mené une enquête en décembre auprès de
800 étudiants qui a révélé que pour la
majorité parfois été en décrochage ou
n'arrivait plus à suivre les cours à
distance
et puis on a dû s'adapter à un format
d'enseignement numérique qui est tout
nouveau pour nous et à la faculté c'est
très compliqué tous les cours sont pas
forcément adaptés un enseignement à
distance ont beaucoup d'étudiants
d'emballer nous pas les équipements
numériques nécessaires en environnement
de travail suffisant pour travailler
donc
donc je pense que ce qui était plus dur
c'est vraiment ce passage au numérique
en réalité non plus évidemment de du
manque d'impact sur sociales qui en
découlent sont vos sources quand on les
entend ils ont quand même un âge assez
différent il ya cette peur de l'inconnu
du lendemain est-ce que vous en tant que
praticienne vous arrivez à à rassurer
sur cette notion là où même vous
finalement une situation aussi inédite
est complexe et il faut faire des
recherches et vous réfléchissez sur vous
même ça a toujours arriver à les
rassurer je ne sais pas parce qu'au fond
ce qui est important c'est que chacun
puisse mobiliser ses propres ressources
on est tous différent en terme de
ressources de vulnérabilité bien
évidemment cela introduit vraiment de
profondes modifications de profonds
bouleversements dans notre manière de
vivre d'être aux autres d'être au monde
la numérisation l'enseignement à
distance
je pense par exemple que là on peut
c'est fondamental de reprendre la
maîtrise du temps et de l'espace
ça c'est quelque chose qui est vrai pour
les salariés pour les étudiants qui sont
à distance de pouvoir s'organiser quelle
que soit la surface dont on dispose
mais un espace dédié au travail en
espace dédié à la vie personnelle
le temps également de passe à laisser
échapper les rythme veille sommeil
l'action peut on peut reprendre la
maîtrise reste voilà donc certains
lâcher prise et de mise à la chefferie
sur cette réalité extérieure sur ce que
l'on est soit profondément le choix du
métier
encore une fois ne jamais renoncer c'est
ce qui nous porte et on n'est pas tous
et et par les mêmes les mêmes outils les
mêmes ressources
on peut dire autres meetings période
il vient mettre à jour des
problématiques plus anciennes qui n'ont
peut-être pas été élaboré et c'est en
cela que ça fait les déflagrations sont
difficiles et douloureusement est ce que
l'un d'entre vous fiona lucas ou sylvain
vous avez eu besoin à un moment soit
d'aller consulter un professionnel soin
de vous rapprocher de vos parents et vos
proches de vos amis lucas andrieu
peut-être oui oui évidemment c'est vrai
que on me donne beaucoup mais on se sent
isolé et je veux juste revenir sur ce
qui a été dit précédemment par rapport
au fait de dirt maîtriser le temps et
l'espace
après premier confinement soit pendant
le premier continent et à 40 % des
étudiants en logements poussent donc en
venant signataires qui sont restés
devant leur appartement et 103,2
importants qui font entre 15 et 20 mai
de garder les nôtres on est dans des
situations on doit manger dans notre
espace de travail
dormir dans le travail et donc c'est et
c'est très compliqué de prendre ça en
main et je pense qu'il faut le
mentionner parce que parce que les unes
en son nom sont précaires finances
financièrement et d'un point de vue du
logement également et donc et donc ça
j'ai des difficultés à tout ça et je
pense qu'on a tous eu besoin de se
rapprocher de sa famille ou de ses amis
c'est parfois impossible le temps pour
les étudiants étrangers de l'université
de verser 50 ans qui n'ont pas tous pu
rentrer chez eux parce que fermeture des
frontières parce que problèmes
financiers et donc et donc c'est vrai
c'est pas si grave est la suivante à des
étudiants je pense justement l'impact
financier le délégué général de la
république en marche stanislas guérini
propose un prêt de dix mille euros pour
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans sans condition
et à taux zéro c'est une proposition
jugée intéressante par le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire est ce que
vous êtes tous les trois concernés par
cette tranche d'âge est ce que c'est une
bonne idée
ce prêt peut-être sylvain mentions vous
êtes c'est vous qui allez rentrer dans
les études supérieures de ce prêt ou
effectivement il peut être intéressant
notamment bas pour les jeunes qui vont
rentrer dans les cycles supérieurs ça
peut déjà donner un avantage après avoir
ce que ça peut réellement donné ce qu'il
peut faire réellement avec quoi sandrine
boussioux sais ce que c'est pas aussi
peut-être mettre un poids supplémentaire
sur les épaules d'un jeune puisque le
prêt serait remboursable sur 30 ans
uniquement si on atteint un certain
niveau de salaire commencé peut-être à
18 ans avec un prêt de dix mille euros
parce que ce serait pas trop lourd qu'en
pensez vous quand il est déjà difficile
de se projeter à 15 jours l'idée de
plâtre en temps voilà comment on peut
dire ces messages paradoxaux qui rendent
quand même la situation très très très
difficile à vivre
après voilà contractent un prêt voilà
c'est une affaire personnelle mais là le
message qui est envoyé vous rembourserai
dans 30 ans alors que qu'on ne sait pas
vois pas ce qui va se passer d'ici 10 15
jours et ses nuits
c'est incohérent cela ne permet pas
l'individu si vous voulez de ce fait
sereinement ou en cohérence
alors on parle beaucoup depuis de
tallard de l'aspect financier de
l'aspect étudiants ou professionnels il
ya aussi un aspect très fort dans la
jeunesse quand on a 20 ans c'est les
loisirs c'est s'évader
fiona vous faites de la danse où vous
faisiez vous allez nous dire dans une
école à montigny-le-bretonneux
alors cette école dispose déco dispense
des cours en vision depuis le mois de
novembre pour le premier confinement
elle a fait des rattrapages après le
confinement justement est-ce que vous
personnellement vous avez pu reprendre
ou alors comment vivez vous cette
situation alors je n'ai pas pourtant
j'ai pas pu me répondre en présentiel
oui donc j'ai pu reprendre en seconde
c'est vraiment très particulier
[Musique]
je sais pas trop comment expliquer parce
qu'en fait c'est la danse le pratiquent
le plaisir de danser même une petite
heure de paris la physique en général
sont mis au fait qu'on retrouve un
groupe on est tous ensemble
et même si dense et en soi comme par
exemple on va pas recommencer
j'adore ça voilà ça sécrète des
endorphines titre est agréable oui il
manque forcément la présence des autres
l'ambiance la motivation les professeurs
aussi le fait que dans l'harmonie
donc les processeurs sont pas là ces
femmes s'en fout quand même sens et flac
pour superviser un peu c'était mal de
choses auprès des choses comme ça au
niveau de l'esprit c'est très compliqué
à gérer encore de la chance d'être chez
mes parents je peux gérer mon espace
d'une maison mais pour les personnes
puissent content des tout petits tout
espace petit appartement c'était
vraiment compliqué et en même temps du
coup si on ne peut pas parce qu'on est
dans des tout petits on est exclu parce
qu'on peut pas participer par des
particuliers comme situation ming on est
tout seul on s'accroche parce qu'on a
très envie de reprendre donc voilà ça
s'essouffle
parce que ça fait déjà quelques temps
déjà repris et la galloise - personnes
qui se connectent parce qu'en fait est
ce que justement vous parlez de vos
professeurs est ce que vous échangez
avec les professeurs de l'école mais
aussi les autres pratiquants j'imagine
qu'il y a un manque une frustration peut
être la peur de la blessure
ce que la danse c'est le corps qui
travaillent on peut danser sur du
carrelage dans
espace très restreint ce que vous disiez
vous ressentez ça avec les autres
personnes de votre groupe
oui oui carrément on en parle entre nous
avec les professeurs canton plus et qui
a pas de produits en faire une printemps
pour discuter et oui on se sent vraiment
le pas mais je sais qu'elle est toujours
présente cette peur de se blesser
même quand on est en présentiel et que
c'est rassurant d'avoir les voix
lapointe lui quadrillage imagine que vos
loisirs aussi sont fortement impactées
comment vous vous évadez mais
malheureusement ça reste secondaire un
écran parce que tout est fermé quand on
veut aller semer dans un parc qui sont
bien souvent fermés on a des seins
un couvre-feu qui nous empêche pas de
nous on veut même de ne serait-ce que
d'aller courir une demi-heure une heure
on n'a pas toujours le temps quand on
doit faire nos courses de la journée
parce qu'ils ont pu l'être le soir donc
c'est bien ce moment de répit dommage
sylvain mention même question pour vous
qu'est ce qui vous manque le plus de
pouvoir vous évader de pouvoir voir vos
proches
comment vous faites justement pour
oublier un peu cette période
bah je vais rejoindre sketches et lucas
effectivement son restant derrière les
écrans en jouant gardant malheureusement
d'été série c'est vrai que maintenant de
limiter au niveau des sorties ont plus
vraiment aller dans des barques dans des
lieux publics quoi c'est dommage
maintenant on est vraiment limité on est
restreint c'est dommage et sandrine
boussioux justement comment s'évader
quand on a 20 ans et moment de la fête
c'est le moment des amis des sorties est
ce qu'on peut trouver actuellement
quelque chose pour pallier cette
situation je vous parlais tout à l'heure
de la croissance des troubles anxieux en
fait c'est un cercle vicieux en fait la
peur
conduit à éviter à éviter d'être
exposées les privations de libertés
individuelles collectives induit c'est
également cette exposition bref c'est
vraiment à côté ce qui ce qui se nourrit
la peur de la blessure
parce qu'on est seule la peur de la
contravention la règle s'évader
consistait à s'auto centre et enfin
c'est on va passer la dé la même manière
mais on va s'évader avec soin et en soi
alors oui les centres d'intérêts bien
évidemment l'activité physique entre la
pratique en plus avec plaisir
j'imagine de manière intense bien
évidemment le manque est là et c'est
difficile de lui trouver un substitut
ce sont des palliatifs est ce que
justement l'un d'eux l'un de vous trois
à à trouver une autre activité pendant
cette période c'est peut-être lancer
dans une lecture très intensive les
cours de cuisine on sait que on a manqué
de farine dans les commerces est ce que
fiona lucas ou sylvain vous avez eu une
autre activité depuis ce début de crise
fiona peut-être oui oui oui bien sûr
j'ai découvert des choses que je ne
m'autorisais pas à faire avant parce que
je trouvais pas le tendre parce que j'y
pensais pas mais par exemple
effectivement la cuisine je me suis mise
et j'apprends du moment et c'est super
j'ai quand même le snu toucher à des
chutes je ne touche pas habituellement
dans mon quotidien et beaucoup il ya
forcément
voilà qui sont positifs et c'est vrai
que chercher ans 3 les ressources hostis
naples est à la fois ça peut faire peur
parce que c'est bon on a peur d'aller en
soi et d'aller chercher mais après quand
on trouve des pépites et
et surtout on découvre qu'on est capable
de faire des choses qu'on pensait pas
qu'on était capable de les faire donc de
ses intérêts après il faut avoir les
moyens à disposition pour le faire
mais bien sûr que qu' il ya d'autres
choses via tokyo n'a cherché à découvrir
même si l'invention ou lucas andrieu est
ce que vous vous être aussi découvert
peut-être un autre talent une autre
passion que celle que vous aviez avant
tout cette crise sur la cuisine je me
suis exercé donc les signé mais ça reste
enfin moi je reste calme très limité par
le temps et par le le travail au moment
de la fac qui pour moi est en
augmentation et donc du coup ça nous
laissera comme moins de temps j'ai mon
côté en tout cas pour découvrir vos
tentes et d'autres choses si les mots
sur ce je vais vous donner le mot de la
fin sur cette émission
la situation continue a duré s'éternise
un petit peu est-ce que vous avez aussi
dans votre profession une crainte de
cette jeunesse sacrifiée où le mot est
trop fort j'ai plutôt un naturel
optimiste et je crois vraiment à la
ressource de chacun à faire face je
crois que c'est chez nous qu'il a
évoquée l'altruisme le fait de se sentir
utile et peut-être une fois dax était
bien meilleur et puis nos jeunes
semblent quand même pas être inventif et
combatif on va conclure sur ces mots
être combatif garde espoir aussi merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
alors pour ceux qui vous ressentirez une
souffrance en cette période des
plateformes propose bien sûr des
solutions avec le soutien de la région
ile de france la fondation fondamental
permet notamment d'évaluer son état
psychologique et de bénéficier de
consultations trois consultations sont
prises en charge par la région
nous parlions en tout début d'émission
aussi à la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye propose un
dispositif à partir du 28 janvier et
l'état anneaux
c'est la possibilité d'un chèque 6
n'oubliez pas aussi que de nombreuses
associations mettent en place des lignes
d'écouté n'hésitez pas bien sûr à vous
rendre sur les différents sites internet
cette société est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet où notre application mobile on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine et
d'ici là prenez soin de vous
[Musique]